[Music]
Pope Francis arrived in Nagasaki
bringing a message of peace and
demanding world leaders and the use of
nuclear weapons 27,000 people were
instantly killed when the city was
devastated by a nuclear bomb at the end
of the Second World War the Pope laid a
wreath at a Ground Zero memorial to
victims of the bombing it's the first
papal visit to Japan in nearly four
decades with many Catholics waiting in
the rain to hear his message Konerko
mentum en todo mundo cinema nuclear is
convinced as I am that a world without
nuclear weapons is possible and
necessary I ask political leaders in not
to forget that these weapons cannot
protect us from current threats to
national and international security it's
not the first time a pope has decried
nuclear warfare Pope Saint John Paul the
second visited Hiroshima emphasizing
that society should be horrified by it
but Francis has gone further than those
before him saying it threatens humanity
and the environment with catastrophic
destruction arguing the money could be
better used elsewhere in a world where
millions of children and families live
in inhumane conditions the money that
squandered and the fortunes made through
the manufacture upgrading maintenance
and sale of ever more destructive
weapons are an affront crying out to
heaven
as well as giving Sunday Mass in the
Nagasaki baseball stadium the Pope is
visiting Hiroshima the site of the first
atomic blast in 1945 were 78,000 people
instantly died and tomorrow he'll meet
victims of the 2011 Fukushima nuclear
disaster his words are some of the most
outspoken by a pope in recent years the
question is whether world leaders will
sit up and listen mo Birchley Sky News
[Music]